[Musica]
buonasera mi che ho potuto ma c'è la
seconda media e amo il pianeta terra
nella vertenza delle meraviglie c'è il
telescopio la racchetta e la mia
bicicletta o quasi 12 anni e non penso
di fare cose straordinarie
anzi penso di fare cose semplicissime ma
sono qui per condividere con voi il mio
punto di vista la terra è la casa di
tutti
a me piace una casa pulita in cui si
vive bene e dove c'è il rispetto armonia
tra le persone che ci abitano
per questo a settembre in occasione del
friday sfor feature ho manifestato da
solo in piazza nel mio paese stornarella
in provincia di foggia
perché l'ho fatto in quel periodo a
scuola avevamo trattato il cantico delle
creature di san francesco e l'ho sentito
particolarmente vicino a ciò che penso
questi sono i versi dedicati alla terra
lodato silvio signore per sorella nostra
madre terra la quale ci sostenta e
governa e produce diversi frutti con
fiori colorati erba penso che sia un
cantico bellissimo come bellissima e la
terra finché produce frutti fiori
colorati erba temo però che se non
facciamo attenzione al nostro modo di
vivere la terra non riusciremo più a
vedere i suoi colori
per questo con i miei compagni di scuola
avevamo pensato di organizzare qualcosa
in occasione del fighting sfuggire ma
non sapevamo bene cosa fare
l'organizzazione era partito un po lenta
non c'era grande entusiasmo
così ho deciso che era arrivato il
momento di rimboccarmi le maniche e fare
qualcosa anche da solo ma dove vai da
solo
dicevano io ho risposto che ci sarei
andato anche da solo perché in questo
mondo ci vivo
a quel punto ho preso il panino che mi
aveva preparato mamma ho messo nello
zaino preso il mio cartellone e sono
andati in bici in piazza a manifestare
per tutta la mattina sono stato da solo
con la forza della mia idea ecologista è
la provocazione del mio cartellone
qualcuno ci ha avvicinato in cui esito e
su una manifestato insieme a me signore
mi ha offerto una brioche che non ha
accettato qualcun altro e che esso cosa
significassero quelle parole che ho
scritto sul mio cartellone sono in
inglese e chi pena e io mi tengo
d'occhio la nonna qui presente mi ha
convinto ad andare a casa sua per pranzo
è interrotto la via manifestazione per
farla contenta
e nel pomeriggio sono tornato in piazza
a manifestare
a quel punto è arrivato il mio amico
antonio nello già più solo a portarmi la
merenda
io ero felicissimo di vederlo a parte
che sta qui pure lui qui presente anche
altre persone ci hanno raggiunto nel
corso del pomeriggio ma alcune ci hanno
hanno preferito guardarci da lontano in
seguito sono arrivate le interviste dei
giornalisti le chiamate miei genitori e
quale a mio nonno che si chiama
esattamente come me o meglio sono io che
mi chiamo come lui potito ruggiero e in
questo caso è toccato farmi da
segretario
spero che non lo diciate ma li devo
ancora lo stipendio penso che se ne sia
scordato
quella che era partita come
un'esperienza un po deludente si è
rivelata strepitosa perché ha insegnato
che se credi davvero in qualcosa deve
avere il coraggio di farla anche se sei
solo anche se gli altri
all'inizio ti potrebbero prendere in
giro aver preso una posizione e ha
portato a fare esperienze incredibili
che penso e non credo che capitano a
tutti i bimbi di 11 anni ovvero della
metà e forse neanche i grandi per
esempio quanti di voi sono stati iena
per un giorno
tranquilli non mi sono montato la testa
ma ho capito che se hai una buona idea
ci devi credere
e l'idea forse può diventare un progetto
e progetto a sua volta può essere
condiviso
e portare a qualcosa di buono per tutti
però io penso che in futuro sarà tutto
più tecnologico per me fare la raccolta
differenziata riciclare qualsiasi cosa e
usare lo spazzolino in bambù sale la
borraccia e la normalità ma so che se
sono abitudini di tutti il mondo ovvero
il nostro pianeta terra
sarà un posto molto più bello in cui
vivere
mi piace la tecnologia e come ho detto
prima penso che sarà molto più
tecnologico nostro mondo in futuro penso
che fra 30 anni inquinamento dato dalle
automobili non ci sarà sarà rimpiazzato
dalla soluzione che saranno credo tutte
elettriche penso che i problemi
ambientali saranno risolti e che saremo
grimm al cento per cento
io non so ancora cosa voglio fare da
grande
posso l'inventore non lo so ciò di cui
sono sicuro è che continuerò ad amare il
pianeta e che mi impegnerò a diciamo
condividere il pensiero che sia non solo
per me ma per tutti una meraviglia da
proteggere
io grazie
[Applauso]
adesso vi chiederete
credo anche da prima perché ho questo
aereoplanino in mano e pensa che
aeroplano sia strano a tenerlo sul palco
sicuramente non io
perché come ha detto le idee possono
diventare progetti e possono essere
condivisi questo può essere una mia idea
mio progetto e voglio condividerlo
[Applauso]
grazie